anthony blinken is in ukraine's capital
backing that country's government
against the military threat from russia
the neighboring country of belarus is
now letting russian troops and tanks
move into positions north of ukraine
lincoln said this morning that russia's
president can order an attack on a very
short notice holly williams has been
watching this ongoing standoff holly
good morning
good morning well secretary of state
lincoln's visit is a show of support to
ukraine as it looks down the barrel of a
russian invasion although the russian
government denies that it's planning an
attack but russia says it expects a
response this week to its demands to
defuse this crisis including a guarantee
that ukraine will not join nato which
the us says is simply not up for
discussion now russia claims that it's
threatened by nato although some people
in ukraine say that in reality russia's
president vladimir putin is playing a
cold war style game of brinkmanship
trying to extract concessions from the
us and its allies in fact the russian
government has even likened these
tensions to the cuban missile crisis
we've made multiple trips to the front
line in ukraine including just this
month where ukrainian soldiers with
training and arms from america are
fighting russian-backed separatists
meanwhile in kiev ukraine's capital
they've renovated bomb shelters in case
of attack the u.s says its fear is a
so-called false flag operation a staged
incident by russia that it uses as a
pretext for invasion
tony
renovating bomb shelters is never good
holly williams in london for us holly
thank you very much